adrián won't arouse key SPN senior NBA
insider joining us on the program was
good morning how are you good morning
great alright where do we stand here the
NBA's been pretty quiet is that a good
sign or a bad sign I think it's been a
good sign
I mean if if you're if you want the
league back and that's the goal here I
think they're moving toward that Dan and
you know they've been putting all the
contingencies in place and really what
they're waiting for is Adam sober to
just kind of hit the green light here
probably sometime in June but they've
been moving toward it and they've got
you know silvers done a pretty
remarkable job of keeping a lot of the
details very tight even away from his
owners front office the union in terms
of exactly how many teams would come
back I think the site is starting to
narrow down to a one or two site
scenario but there's certainly momentum
toward the leak coming back now when
you're talking about its site or sites
are we talking about Vegas Orlando or
those are the two sites that are in
conversations that's right Dan and
Orlando has had a lot of traction and I
think the questions gonna be you know
are they going to put all the teams in
one place are they gonna perhaps have
teams moving among two sites based on an
Eastern Western Conference scenario but
the one thing Adam silver has told the
players and told the owners what he
doesn't want our teams flying around
you're not gonna see what baseball is
proposing which is teams moving around
playing in home stadiums the NBA's
focused on a one site no fans and then
they're gonna deal with trying to get
back into arenas again buildings again
for the start of next season so just to
recap you're looking at at leat but
maybe one permanent site here for the
postseason or possibly to perm
sites with Vegas and Orlando where you
have East Coast and West Coast teams and
that's possible that's one way they
could do it Dan they may put everybody
in one site the thing that we don't know
yet and I think they're still working
through is are they bringing back all 30
teams are they bringing back just the
playoff teams or something maybe in
between it where you would have let's
say the seven there was a talk last
there was a vote that was actually
coming to do for next year which was the
play in tournament at the end of the
season I mean like a year ago that's all
we were talking about that was the big
issue in the league play in tournament
mid-season tournament but they could
they could in bringing these teams back
do a play in tournament that might that
might take you through the 10th seed or
maybe even the twelve seed and you know
then it's how many teams are you
bringing back do you leave out maybe the
bottom few teams in each conference but
I don't have I think they discussed all
that Dan but they still may very well
bring back off thirty there may be teams
who don't want to be left out in that
way and this is where it gets tougher
out of silver when you have to start
making decisions
I think his handling of the matter has
been very popular within the league and
probably been outside of league but but
it gets more difficult when you start to
have decisions made that have
consequences impact people and then
people are less happy with you has
everybody been paid all of the players
there their entire salaries well
starting on May 15 so I don't even know
what the data is anymore I think it's
the 18th starting on May 15th they
started with hold 25% of the players
remaining salaries so that if games are
canceled and I think we can assume they
least be some regular season games
canceled they're not going to come back
and be able to play them all then the
owners take back a percentage of that
money it's basically 1 percent of player
salaries based on how many games they
miss and so now they've had withholding
taking taken from their salaries so they
don't have to take it all out at once at
the end of the season it's the 19th
watch I was I was wrong I'm right there
with you
like 'ok i at least know the month i
don't know the day we're talking to
adrienne woods and around ski SPN senior
NBA insider are the power brokers in
involved in this Chris Paul LeBron James
some of the other notable players with
the Commissioner Chris Paul is the
president of The Players Association so
he's very much in that conversation Dan
and Michelle Roberts Adam silver they
talk frequently the one advantage that
silver has in this scenario maybe even
over baseball right now I think there's
a stronger relationship between the star
players and the Commissioner maybe not
necessarily owners but the Commissioner
and that helps in selling what has to be
sold here which is the one site concept
that he's gotten feedback from players
about how they feel about that bubble
idea what they might like and not like
about it because he really needs the
cooperation of the Players Association
and and by extension really the star
players because they do drive maybe more
than any other sport
I think they drive the conversation
among the 450 players in the league and
if you can sell your star players and
what it is that you want to accomplish
how you need to do it they can go out
and start selling it with their peers -
and and Adam Silver's understood that
and and he has made his star player is a
big part of the conversation because
there's a lot of real difficult economic
conversations coming between the Union
and the players or the union and the
league and they're going to have to
alter how the salary cap looks for next
year and luxury tax and a lot of boring
dry financial topics that are going to
absolutely have a big impact on
competitive balance in the league what
the leagues really worried about then is
not so much what happens this summer but
what happens next year if they're if
they can't have fans in arenas or if
they have to have like a social
distancing situation with fans we're in
a 20,000 seat arena maybe you could only
have 4,000 or 5,000 people and how do
you how do you manage that because the
revenue stream of the league 40% of it
depends upon basically game-night
receipts I know this sounds crazy but if
we start to inch closer to deeper into
the summer is there any chance the
Commissioner would say I'm going to take
the two top teams in the east and the
two top teams in the West therefore I
can cut down the travel and the number
of people involved in this and I can
reduce the odds of somebody testing
positive you basically have a Final Four
for the NBA could you ever see us
because they are they're bound and
determined to crown a champion here what
they are determined to crown a champion
Dan but I think they want a crown a
legitimate champion and I don't think
that would I don't think they would see
that as legitimacy I don't there won't
be a playoff team left behind now no
come after the playoff teams that may
still be up for debate but one thing out
and silver did say and a call with the
players that his goal was to have seven
game series in each playoff round and
that they wouldn't cut it down to a best
of five in any round and try to make the
champion as legitimate as it can be yeah
I had heard that they were they were
looking at a five-game series for the
first round and then they would
eventually get to seven games but you're
you're refuting that with your
information so I said I think they knew
all of it was based on how many days do
we have to play with you how many days
do we have but the goal is to do it in
seven game series but that doesn't mean
they haven't discussed they've discussed
everything yeah and I do think that was
one of the conversations and what would
that look like I know their preference
is to try to keep those playoffs
best-of-seven all the way through I'll
leave you here's what you don't want in
the first round I mean if you you don't
want a one eight upset like this isn't
the last thing you want is a five-game
series where the eight seed better
chance I mean come on we know you don't
really want that no I'll leave you with
this are we pushing back the 2021 season
no matter what happens the rest of the
summer
I think it's increasingly likely Dan and
I think pushing it back gives the league
next year more more time to have more
dates where they could have fans in the
arena because if you
started in mid-october which he can't do
anyway if this season pushes into late
September in September it just buys the
league more time to kind of kick kick
the can down the road to have fans and
buildings because that's what they're
really worried about if you were
covering Jordan now in that last year
with the questions that have emerged
from that like how would you approach
that as an NBA insider of you know the
flu game or then food poisoning game
Jerry Krause Phil Jackson you know can
you bring him back like could you let us
into your world of how you think you
would have approached that in today's
world I think that one difference then
might have been and there was immortal
NBA writers media then who are covering
a day-to-day I think there's more
attention now on the salary cap and the
financial impact of of the decision
Scottie Pippen might have had on a
one-year fourteen million dollar deal
verse doing the sign and trade I think
there would have been more attention
paid to the economics and a cap and how
difficult it would have been to bring
the whole group back I think that's
probably a small difference in it not
not the other stuff with Jordan I think
it was all covered I just think we I
just think it was covered in newspapers
it was covered on SportsCenter I don't
get the sense it wasn't all covered I
just think that the platforms were
different and it didn't inundate us like
it might with social media now but how
would social media have affected Michael
Jordan ooh good question and if it's
affected every great player that I've
ever covered or been around and because
if you're looking for slights like go
for self-affirmation like if your little
e not the place you'd go probably even
for Michael Jordan yeah
hey what great stuff and thanks for
joining us we appreciate your time
absolutely that's Adrian wood Generale
ski the woods podcast there where he
discusses the hottest topics around the
league only on the woge podcast